avec jérôme marty médecin et président
du syndicat des médecins de l'union
française pour une médecine libre
bonsoir gérant de marquis merci d'être
avec nous on vient de le voir l'exemple
marié honte est davantage que dans le
reste du pays
vous saluer cette initiative c'est ce
qu'il faudrait peut-être ailleurs en
france
tester tester tester c'est ce que vit le
msc ce qu'il faut faire effectivement
mais on voit que langkow on a un retard
qui est très important on a un retard en
termes de moyens de protection les
masses que les surblouse l'ailé et
surchaussures les écrans de protection
il a fallu que ce soit des entreprises
qui les fabriquent des entrées des
imprimantes 3d on n'a toujours pas eu
véritablement de moyens et puis les
tests on est très en retard alors le
gouvernement la boutique que l'on va
être en capacité de faire 500 me le test
par semaine on a envie de le croire
malheureusement le passé a montré que
chaque fois qu'on a voulu donner en
quelque sorte une date butoir elle a été
très largement dépassé ce qui est
certain c'est que ce virus va faire
partie de nos vies pendant encore des
mois et des mois et des mois
on rappelle qu'il ya mahdi % de la
population à peine qui est immunisée
renault n'a pas de traitement
elle en a pas de vaccins que là un peu
de tests et que l'on a peu de masques
donc par rapport à ça il ne reste plus
que les gestes barrière il ne reste plus
que le civisme de chacun d'entre nous
pour arriver à continuer à maintenir
cette épidémie en deçà de la capacité de
prise en charge et faire que la courbe
continue à se casser je rappelle que
pour l'instant on est sur un plateau
avec des oscillations que le nombre de
morts est très sous-évalué faut le
répéter à l'envi parce que monsieur
salomon nous donne toujours une vision
très parcellaire
il ne compte qu'une comptabilise que
l'été c'est un hôpital et fort
heureusement maintenant enfin fort
heureusement si on peut dire maintenant
les décès également en ehpad
établissements médico-sociaux et
toujours rien sur la ville
toujours rien n'est sûr les domiciles
toujours rien sur la précarité sur la
solitude etc
jérôme maquillage
justement concernant ces tests vous
l'avez dit l'objectif est de 500 mille
tests edouard philippe a fait comprendre
ça va être l'une des clés de cette
stratégie de déconfinement mais il
n'arrive pas un peu tard parce qu'on
rappelle cette grande différence majeure
c'est est ce sont des tests pcr qui
permettent de savoir si oui ou non on a
le virus dans l'instant mais ce ne sont
pas des tests de sérologie qui
permettent de savoir si on est oui ou
non immunisés donc c'est pas vraiment
trop tard justement de tester les
personnes qui se sont confinés qui a
priori ne rompt pas le virus
non c'est pas trop tard parce qu'encore
une fois il ya que 10% de la population
qui est immunisée donc je le virus a
aussi reculé
vous savez que le confinement est saigné
du nez - imposer une cloche sur les
incendies l'étouffer mêlée samedi est
toujours en vie et quand on va re
soulevé la cloche le risque c'est que
cela reprenne cela reprenne par kodak au
chapeau logé entre chacun d'entre nous
et que l'épidémie re diffuse à partir de
là il faut qu il soit une capacité de
tester le gouvernement lui aussi tester
les gens c'est automatique
on rappelle qu'il ya une immense
proportion de cas asymptomatiques
il faut certainement certainement visé
en tout cas ceux qui ont les plus grands
elle seule entre nous que les plus
grande interaction sociale c'est à dire
ce qu'il voit le plus de monde et cela
il faut bien les tester de façon
aléatoire contrairement à ce que dit le
ministre et je m'inscris en faux
il y à des pays qui vous fait du test
aléatoire c'est la corée du sud
c'est daiwa house et l'islande il ya des
pays qui vont le faire c'est la suède le
québec on est très loin du discours de
monsieur vérone autre clé du
déconfinement les masses car là aussi on
a fait des petits élèves sont les
masques obligatoire dans les transports
on en parle beaucoup mais pas forcément
à l'école la réaction du médecin
l'action du médecin c'est que la même
que celle que je tienne depuis des
semaines mais bécaud et soeurs et mes
confrères aussi le masque c'est pas un
compliment qu'on a pu le dire là aussi
le ministre c'est pas un complément aux
gestes barrières récepteur c'est quelque
chose d'indispensable
et j'insiste bien là dessus c'est
indispensable
chaque fois que la distanciation social
au physique doit être rompu dans les
transports en commun notamment vous
devez tous porter des masques parce que
nous
tous potentiellement porteurs
asymptomatiques vous pouvez donc
contaminer les gens qui sont autour de
vous le masque est masquée écran c'est
fait pour protéger votre entourage et
donc vous devez bien évidemment le
porter quand edouard philippe dit il
faudra s'habituer on va vivre encore
longtemps avec ce virus alors que
s'amorce une stratégie de déconfinement
on est plutôt en retard en france vous
est-ce que vous restez néanmoins
optimiste éventuellement sur une
disparition du virus on entendait le
professeur raoul dire que ce virus
cette épidémie pourrait disparaître au
printemps est ce que il ya un espoir
goûtez moi j'ai pas de boule de cristal
pour ce que je regarde ce sont à la fois
les chiffres ce sont les retards ce sont
les manquements
oui oui bien sûr il ya un espoir oui on
va arriver à dominer cette pathologie de
toute façon il y aura un vaccin
on va aussi découvrir les traitements on
en apprend tous les jours mais en
attendant en attendant il va être là
pendant des mois et je pense aujourd'hui
effectivement aux restaurateurs vous
allez parler yannick alléno qui sera
avec vous sur cette chaîne tout à
l'heure on ne peut que penser à ou aux
autres et aux ateliers qui ne peuvent
pas réouvrir qui ont des situation
financière catastrophique qu'il va
falloir aider et là aussi si on avait eu
les moyens
si on avait eu les moyens de protection
suffisamment tôt si on avait eu des
tests suffisamment tôt on n'en serait
peut-être pas là aujourd'hui en tout cas
on serait plus avancées dans la lutte
contre cette épidémie qu'on ne l'est
aujourd'hui
et puis je pense aussi juste dans
quelques mots je pense aussi à l'état
des cabinets des médecins de ville des
tables et des soignants libéraux qui
aujourd'hui ont d'une perte financière
qui est immense qui risque de précipiter
leur cabinet daver la fermeture parce
que il ya eu des mots malheureux là
encore de la part de ceux qui nous
gouvernent qui ont appelé les patients à
ne pas aller trouver dans médecin
généraliste ou alors juste en extrême
urgence et ses patients ont coupé les
ponts ce qui a fait non seulement
prendre des risques à ses patients mais
qui en plus qui en plus a menacé
directement la pérennité économique de
ces cabinets qui si on les aide pas ils
vont s'ajouter un vaste audit de
nozières médicaux on sent très
rapidement jérôme article sur ce point
le le gouvernement rétropédale
olivier verrons vraiment appeler les
français à les consulter pour d'autres
centres d'autres maladies ça récupère
peut-être un petit peu les choses à vos
yeux
non ça récupère pas pourquoi je vais
vous dire pourquoi depuis le début on a
oublié qu'il existait une médecine de
ville et quand je dis médecine entendre
forme à sierre entendent infirmières
aides soignantes auxiliaires de vie
qu'il existe un tissu sanitaire de ville
ce tissu sanitaire s'occupe de 95% des
patients covit j'insiste bien sur ce
chiffre quatre-vingt-quinze pour cent
ce tissu sanitaire a été présent depuis
le début la majorité des gens qui sont
tombés chez les médecins qui sont
décédés malheureusement saône des
libéraux personne n'en parle à personne
c'est dommage cette profession à cette
part de la profession
on a des hommages pour les hospitaliers
je les salue on a vu des artistes qui
font des chansons sur l'hôpital on a un
grand quotidien qui aujourd'hui offre
gratuitement aux membres de l'hôpital
on a des formes qui lève des frais qui
lève de l'argent pour l'hopital
encore une fois je salue je sais quel
est le métier là et la dureté pour
rencontrer nos confrères seraient nos
confrères hospitaliers
mais quand même de grâce de grâce on
n'oublie pas que j'existe médecine de
ville
merci beaucoup jérôme marty médecin et
président du syndicat de médecins de
l'union française pour une médecine
libre merci d'avoir été avec mon sur rt
france